yeah okay we carry the Zipit empathy
I know patience is the key put it out on
my ship for free this is t we carry feet
Michael make the friend oh is and so
abruptly you know so abruptly hello
everybody I'm sorry I'm five minutes
late I just had an executive call it was
April 22nd I am Gary Vaynerchuk this is
tea with Gary Vee Dustin on the ones and
twos let's get it going
please share the URL on Facebook Twitter
YouTube tag some friends let's get some
new friends in the mix let's get into
the show Wow Wow
hi how are you nice to see it it's great
to see you this is fun how you doing I'm
really good how are you doing I'm really
well thank you for asking
Luz well everybody's hanging in yeah
we're in the mountains in Colorado and
I'm natural Rekluse so I'm doing good
I'm glad I'm glad my team was trying to
keep this a secret but I saw something
so I knew you were coming so I'm super
excited that you're here boys you have
any questions not particularly good
you're gonna play a little music yeah
are we on in live sorry on in life we
are yeah I'm just thinking about how are
people doing when I look at this
pandemic I really see is this threefold
thing I see yeah
the virus is obviously one pillar and
the economic fallout which I don't think
we've quite gotten a grip on what that's
gonna be and then the mental health
fallout we have to nearly double during
recessions and that's never been during
a pandemic or during isolation suicide
hotlines are up 300% I have a Youth
Foundation where all we do is help kids
with suicidal ideation what have you
seen in like in your comments and your
fans talking out their anxiety that I
think a lot of people are struggling and
so I have seen a little bit of a silver
lining I've spoken to a couple people
who are getting help through this kind
of interaction
video which now which they thought
similar to me with meetings they thought
they needed to be in the room with their
person whoever that may be and they've
been able to get the value through this
which makes it feel scalable which one
of when a one fan who I've gotten
friendly with you know now feels that
she can travel because she can do it on
the laptop versus being in the room and
and so I you know like everything
there's always the pros and the cons but
yes there's a lot of anxiousness and I
think to your point the the
ramifications on the economy post this
there's a lot of people out of jobs
slash consumer behavior will change
forever yeah you know if you know what
don't we know you know what don't we
know that has changed forever
in retail in restaurant and trap I mean
you can imagine a world that even 24
months from now travel is down 20 to 35
percent you know or hotels or conference
yeah there's just a lot there's a lot
yeah my main concern is helping trying
to help people we're gonna come out of
this one or two ways we're gonna be more
resilient more capable we're gonna say
these are ideas that no longer serve me
beliefs and systems and functions
that's real these are ones that are
going to replace them because I've used
this time to be really thoughtful or
people are gonna become so anxious and
so worried which is understandable but
if we don't understand what to do with
worry and anxiety it's gonna escalate
into pathologies and I could foresee a
world where many people come out of this
more afraid more scared more
disempowered then they will they will
for a certain period of time in certain
ways you know I mean look what liquid
9/11 did to a lot of people completely
changed our frameworks their political
views their their anxieties so yeah I
mean this is a real world event this
will be this will be talked about
hundreds of years after were gone so
there's real stuff this is real yes for
me I am with the kids so I've been
working with kids for 18 years the youth
foundation called inspiring children and
I give them a toolkit of mindfulness in
motion tools so mindfulness has two
components in my eyes meditation which
is one and then you have to
exercise like the gym if you go to the
gym you build a muscle that's great but
unless you use that muscle during the
day it's not gonna change your life
meditation is the same way meditation
actually builds a muscle they've learned
in eight weeks it can grow new folds in
your frontal lobes and shrink your
amygdala anxiety lives but if you don't
put that muscle to work it isn't gonna
change your life so the tools that I
developed actually developed him while I
was homeless but they were recently
proven to work by a neuroscientist named
dr. Judson Brewer to help rewire your
brain
thanks to neuroplasticity which is just
a fancy way of saying you starve old
habits and you build new ones so the
kids and I put the tools up on a free
website called Joule never broken calm
and there's no calm yeah Jule never
broken calm and it's free 3-minute
exercises that actually will help rewire
you and one of the main things I wanted
to just because I know we don't have a
ton of time but I just wanted to kind of
put this in people's ears that there's
only two basic states of being
there's dilated and then there's
contracted both are important but when
you do them at the wrong time it can be
really uncomfortable so joy gratitude
curiosity observation helps you dilate
relax and that's actual neurological
neurotransmitter and vascular everything
changes contraction is anxiety theory
were theory word out anger etc and you
can't be in two states at once so the
best hack that I ever learned for
anxiety for me when I was homeless you
know my car I was living in got stolen
it was awful I was having panic attacks
agoraphobia and I learned that if I was
heading into a highly anxious state I
could feel my full body constrict I just
had to profoundly make myself have a
thought or a feeling that dilated me and
I always used gratitude your vascular
system dilates your transmitters change
it's really profound and no matter how
little you have there is something to be
grateful for so there's an exercise that
kind of helps you practice that on the
website but I wrote a song called
grateful just because I felt like that
was the medicine that helped me and I
know you're big on gratitude
by the way what you're doing with the
all end is incredible that's thank you
using it's been so
awesome it's been really fun I think I
want to enter all those raffles I'll hit
you up after this you could do amazing
things you can but you could have d1 can
you play can you play a little bit of it
and then I'm gonna get to some of the
questions - good - good you are so
amazing
cool thank you so much for being on that
website up one more time Dustin q what's
the website one more time never broken
calm and I just launched this song great
full of people and I check it out we are
gonna check it out jump love you take
care of yourself we'll talk about it man
if I could sing I'd be in a whole nother
level I'll just listen to that I was
like [ __ ] man
anyway let's keep it going fun way to
start the morning Gino
Gary what's good bro good morning man
how you doing I'm really well what can I
help you with uh I had a question for
you man so so I'm an artist I was always
a artist it's kind of I got into music
but recently I started to spawn right
way to kind of get break in the end
and I've had a lot of success like
multi-platinum things going really well
hey but recently I you know we decided
to kind of kick off the artist thing and
go full in on that I recently dropped a
record and so I'm kind of shifting my
focus back into into being an artist but
I don't want to lose the songwriting
momentum so I guess my question is both
alright you have you have it in you yeah
like like people think about things in
theory like there's a theory that if
you're not all in are one or the other
you can't pull it off when that makes no
[ __ ] sense right like I'm I'm running
the most successful fastest the most the
fastest-growing agency in Madison Avenue
which is hardcore [ __ ] it's competitive
I'm competing it's multi-billion dollar
companies and I'm building one of the
most prolific personal brands there's so
many people that want to be Garry be on
social media that that's all they do yet
it's the minority of what I do I spend
most of my time being an actual
executive right and launching uppity
wines and helping my dad with white text
and you know like you've got it you've
got that in you you know like if you
wake up in the morning you feel like you
want to write something boom if you want
to go in the studio and keep that song
for you boom if you want to give that
song to the baby boom like like there is
no [ __ ] rules right right yeah yeah
it's in your head or people around you
saying yo if you don't go all in on one
thing you're gonna have your ass on two
toilets and you're not gonna be able to
pull it off
yeah I think a lot of it is like it's
not so much a concern that I can't do
both because I know I can I've been you
know I've been doing it um I think a lot
of it is just trying to find the balance
of like cuz I don't do it like six seven
sessions a week on the on the right and
the right into it um so yeah I don't
like this so do four right let's talk
about writing you know it's one song
yeah
ya know so there bro you know it's not
seven songs a week it's right right one
[ __ ]
banger that changes your whole life
forever right right thanks
no I think you're judging yourself for
no reason
do whatever the feels right you want to
go three straight weeks on a [ __ ]
binge writing tour Mazel Tov you want to
go in the [ __ ] booth for a month good
you want to do one day one day one day
my biggest issue that I'm trying to
change in the world is people judging
themselves just do what the [ __ ] feels
right yeah you let me ask you do you do
you okay so you're running so much [ __ ]
at once do you are there like periods
where you prioritize something like I
gotta go in on this today I go yeah like
today I have to do a call with my London
office to look at their finances so tea
with Gary B is not 9:00 to 11:00 it's
9:00 to 10:00 right I prioritized I
prioritized the London office yeah I was
five minutes late for this I prioritized
my epic Hall with the tracer team tracer
doc tech if you're looking at some
software to help you with your social
fear big company so you know like I
prioritize that be [ __ ] second but I
don't make some master plan and write on
a paper and think this is gonna be my
next four hundred days yeah everyone had
a five-year plan until some lady eat a
bat in China and [ __ ] it all up
what happened to your [ __ ] five-year
plans now everybody well your [ __ ]
five-year plan out some lady ate a back
in China and [ __ ] your [ __ ] up on some
real [ __ ] that would be not a joke that
I would make a year ago to talk about
don't make five-year plans yeah you know
prioritize daily not yearly not in the
macro not on a [ __ ] excel sheet not
on my [ __ ] pad I live it right I
think that's been the the blessing of if
there is that of this whole thing is
like I've been if I'm feeling doing it
today if I wake up and I'm like am NOT a
spy I don't force it I do something else
that you know it give me your audience
right yeah don't force but don't lay in
bed and just well on everything do you
do you nope you yeah
all right let's go let's go let's go
Gino in the building Oh
Joel how are you great how are you doing
I'm quite well good it's great to see
you yeah I good to see you
I enjoyed reading a little bit in your
biography about how as a child you
became an entrepreneur I had the same
experience I was 11 when I started my
first business I love that what are you
doing I was delivering fresh vegetables
that I'd grown around the neighborhood I
heard my little brother - take him
around the neighborhood and the red
Radio Flyer wagon I love that have you
been hanging it yeah pretty well all
things considered I mean the airline
industry is a tough one I'm in a bunch
of other businesses as well but the
airline business is particularly our did
airlines hotels cruise ships I think are
the three toughest I think that's right
I think that's right what can I help you
in just a ger to talk with you about it
whatever you want to talk about you know
I'm I'm kind of in a place where I think
there's an enormous amount of
opportunity you know I think that right
now everyone's got a kind of settle into
the realities you know I think they have
to cross their T's and dot their eyes
but but for me all I want to talk about
is offense and optimism that's such a
great message I think it's going to
reshuffle the deck I think the people
that are the most creative have the most
ingenuity our best grounded in
principles and and I've just written
this book called the entrepreneurial
leader which i think is going to be
required of everyone is to be more
entrepreneurial and resides no more
managers no more administrators it's
really going to require leaders to be
entrepreneurial and and and and that
goes in my mind as creative you've got
to just rethink you know the status quo
is is extremely dangerous
when innovation is required and this
this moment requires enormous innovation
rethinking and most of all humility many
are gonna struggle going back into the
world and not having the same amount of
money the same amount of status the same
amount
opportunity you know organizations that
go from 800 to 437 are gonna require all
437 to work we're at 800 they had the
fact to get away with being in meetings
yeah yeah I think that's exactly right I
think it's gonna require a lot of things
of people one of the things that I think
leaders are gonna have to do better is
communicate more directly bad news as
well as good news before during and
after the fact I actually think it's
going to require people to be kinder I
think I don't people don't think about
that but I think there are a lot of
people who are vulnerable and I think a
word of kindness you know dropping
somebody a note giving them a call
checking up on them making sure they're
okay and I think volunteering I've given
blood a couple of times I'm scheduled to
give blood another time here and I think
it you kind of lose yourself in helping
others I think that's a good way to get
through these kinds of crises I think
that's right my friend I really
appreciate you being on yeah my pleasure
yeah have a great great day Joel all
right take care of it I know thanks man
let's keep it going what's going on Gary
appreciate you not so I have a bit of a
I have a question specific to to my
situation now but it makes sense to give
you a bit of a backstory so I'm 38 from
Toronto Canada
I had a just shy of a 10 years run at
finance I built up a career in finance I
guess it fairly well I I could have
swore I was happy making good money low
stress and then about two years ago I
sort of questioned everything you know
it's sort of just hit me like a ton of
bricks like what am i doing what makes
me happy
long story short I you know I did long
story short I decided to quit my passion
is audio engineering something I've
always wanted to do mixing records
working in the studio so I pulled the
trigger I did it not knowing how I was
gonna pan out because I had no
preparation I didn't have any friends in
the industry
I had no basis to go on I was really on
my own on this one and like nobody in my
circle that really unders
of my situation it was sort of like
everybody's it's the easiest situation
understand you decided to choose
happiness over being content safe and
having some money right I mean my wife
thought I was crazy at first my friends
thought I was crazy
you know what you weren't happy well
well I think it's crazy that 98 percent
of people that watch this don't do that
[ __ ] mm-hmm I think so too I think you
were awake I could I could have swore I
was happy I mean it's almost like you
were cop you were happy in the conscious
that you were cannot be in the
subconscious you weren't right
you were happy in the practical it you
were happy in what you have been taught
as a 38 year old is winning you were
happy in the fake right right you you
know you weren't happy you know at 34 on
a on a on a map or or 32 on driving to
work or 37 on during a shower that that
quick thought passed through your head
mm-hmm sure jumping at 38 means that
you've been building since 28 to that
moment maybe definitely definitely
I'm telling you little little moments
not like every day at 28 28 you're like
yeah I got that money you know but I
promise you it was chipping away mm-hmm
for sure so so I did it now maybe we can
get into maybe a strategic play into
where I'm at now sure but but I'm almost
more passionate about what I it's crazy
because I'm unpassable what I'm doing
now but I mean it just needs me to
wonder how many people are actually in
that state that I was in everybody I
think I'm almost as passionate about
helping people maybe realize that maybe
you know I want to be with you but you
you have a lot of legs to stand on right
you did it you know one of the reasons I
love being a known entrepreneur in this
game right now is because I actually did
it and a lot of them known entrepreneurs
are just talking about being
entrepreneurs so you
they're making their money selling
people on how to make money not they've
ever actually made some so the fact that
you have the balls to do it and the
strength and the inner strength to do it
is gonna be massively inspirational I
would argue that you need to be careful
that you're not going down that path
because you think there's more money in
it than the audio engineering thing so
you've got to balance that and you got
to ask yourself am I looking to do that
because there's dollars in selling
people to do that or is that actually my
passion or is it because the audio
engineering thing doesn't have the
finances in the first five years that I
may have been accustomed to that's a
real next challenge for you and your own
dome for sure okay so maybe I can maybe
we can get into maybe a strategic place
to where I'm at now so basically when I
quit I didn't know how this is gonna pan
out I didn't like I said I didn't have
any connection to industry I've sort of
been building myself over the last year
to really get : him on my craft and
build my chops I think early on I
started the whole promotion thing like I
set up a website and it didn't take me
very long to figure out like oh [ __ ]
this is an art form like this is gonna
take me a bit of time to to really you
know master and and I think I'm I'm sort
of getting there it's been a year and a
half now and and I think I'm ready to
start promoting and started like I'm
building a portfolio got some clients
now it's definitely kind of lining up
but I think up until now I haven't done
the whole social media thing just
because I didn't want to do it
prematurely I didn't want to something
not deliver so what's the strategic play
like I mean what was I be content I mean
I don't even but that's actually the
game you know there's a lot of people
that are already your engineers - mm-hmm
there's a lot of people that went into
the finance industry - this is the
supply and demand of content is is not
the issue the ability to deliver value
to somebody on the other side is the
issue mm-hmm the way I've sort of been
hesitant because I mean like I said it
is not for him it takes take some but
you could have documented the journey of
becoming there like you could have been
a huge inspiration yeah you know I you
know I don't know how long you've been
watching me but the document over
creating is a big thing I would argue
that your journey in that first 18
months of going from 0 and quitting to
be
coming an audio engineer was some of the
best content you could have ever put out
you know expertise audio engineering
content could could be more commoditized
than being 38 and jumping into or 36 or
whatever math less and jumping into your
passion so you know there's always
opportunities to bring value as a
content creator for everybody's watching
if they stay in their truth and they
play out the snowflake game which is
like we're all unique and I think the
you know what I'm what I'm the best in
the world that is being 100% me mm-hmm
and I think you will be 100% you and
telling those stories and showing the
crappy content versus you know the audio
work versus the good work like I think
there's power in that and then people
become aware of you and awareness is
branding which leads to buying we don't
buy coca-cola or Nike because they sold
us we just know it and we buy it and
then if we figure out if we like it
right right okay I appreciate the
content just start talking all right I'm
glad you picked that I can tell you got
me pick that up thank you take care well
it's coming in yeah no one knows Crystal
Maze what's good besides are bright
thank you for being here something out
the waters love it thank you for being
here let's keep it going
hey Gary hey Karen
Corinne actually yes no you're fine a
couple of questions bear with me a
little bit nervous big fan of yours I
listen to you all the time I'm actually
looking for advice or strategies on
getting away from codependency in
business so I've restarted in my life
completely about a year ago I left my
first career and I'm chasing my desires
now working in a luxury real estate
market and I don't know a lot about real
estate so I joined a team and I met some
amazing people that were helping guide
me through but I kind of went off on my
own although I don't have that
confidence anymore so I find myself
really trying to rely on other people in
order to get where any
um that's a mistake I know great you
know like I think what you need to do is
realize it's okay that you don't know
anything you're just starting right you
know like you're in the Lord you need to
put this into the learning you need to
make this the learning process not the
dependency process like do you not enjoy
the fact that they have leverage on you
do not enjoy the fact that you have
self-doubt like you're gonna sign it
yeah yeah Bush the [ __ ] know it
immediately know right well I want to be
able to have educated conversation
because these are individuals who are
not it's not like buying a brand new
column and you have to you know explain
something this is a secondary market so
people who are generally looking for
luxury are a lot more advanced in their
knowledge and then what people buy B
people buy from people correct right
yeah somebody who spends a lot of time
with you know individuals who you know
buy homes and secondary markets it's
like they they oftentimes know what they
want more than what the real estate
agent even after twenty you know what I
mean talk about like like the real
estate agent is really just on a trust
game and do they like them yeah and the
education on the data is here the comps
of what the homes sold for like it's not
like you know like people that have are
in affording a second home have
oftentimes are in a place where they
make good decisions they're either made
really good decisions they really know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about or
the complete hucksters and they're about
to lose everything at some point in next
ten years and actually don't give a [ __ ]
about anything but looking cool and
doing their things so I would argue with
you that secondary home real estate
macro DNA is actually even more about
people's skills and the things that you
need to learn I'm watching my sister
become highly more educated over the
last two two years in her real estate
journey and she started ad zero and was
concerned about it III think you're
making a mountain out of a molehill okay
okay
well so just kind of leads in some other
thing what you were saying about it's
more of a people skill I've actually had
a couple of individuals in the small
town reach out to me that want
muta - promotional brand ambassador they
presented some opportunities for that
and I'm I'm fearful to stretch myself
too thin because I'm wanting to pursue
this luxury market but then I have a
garage who's who's wanting to get me out
there and do some promoting for them to
get more business and then I have a sub
you know because you have you have a big
following or no I don't
that's what's wild to me they think I
don't have the part I'm assuming yeah
I'm assuming I mean look that's up to
you that just comes down to are the
economics interesting for you right now
in the short term what I would tell you
is you need to be careful because you
don't want to dilute your brand and when
I hear a CBD company and garage like I
want it you know you need to decide if
you want to be model life or if you want
to be real estate agent and by the way
you can do both it all just depends on
do you feel good about the Association
okay you know every time you're putting
yourself there like you're associating
and so you need to be managed yeah and
so yes your image for sure you know
number two you need to make sure you
believe in the business what if god
forbid the business is [ __ ] and you
know and now on the flip side I never
judge people's short-term financial
needs
right so it's always a friction point
like is that five thousand bucks more
important than the long-term brand
association but because the real estate
thing will be patients plus I'm sure
you're no dope you realize that second
home buying may be slowing down a little
bit here for a little while
yep definitely so these are all the
navigations but you get to make those
decisions just go into making those
decisions with eyes wide open so do you
have a suggestion on finding appropriate
mentors in the situation because this is
new to me and I came from the medical
field where people are telling me do
this do this do this and we'll pay you
now I'm in a position where I kind of
get to figure it out myself and I don't
know how I'm torque mentors tend to be
bad because mentors 85% I'm give advice
that worked for them
okay and so hey be careful of that
because mentors like to give the
blueprint that they took and so I think
what you need to do is just consume
information but you also just have to
make decisions and taste it I promise
you this no you know brand deal with
something is gonna forever kill your
brand right don't let what I said
earlier scare you I just want you to be
thoughtful because once you go down that
rabbit hole you could be doing twenty
seven deals later and now your brand's
diluted right and then the friction of
transitioning maybe a little bit more
difficult or you just might get caught
up in the hamster wheels of the quote
unquote easier money and that's what I'm
trying to avoid I don't want to just
become another you know promo model
first just anything at this point I want
to yeah I want to have it all thing down
specially for my lynching but but you
can do both you know and you can evolve
you know JLo Tyra Banks you know they
start in one place J Lo's a dancer on in
living color now she's a entrepreneurial
global icon right absolutely you're
young enough to pull it off so what I
would say is be thoughtful but don't be
fearful okay got it got it thank you
Carrie all right let's keep it going
then what's good Gary what's up man so
on jump right in through it um I'm the
kind of person who likes to have like a
couple different projects going at once
so I definitely want to ask you about
one and then if you have like 30 seconds
at the end for the other one that would
be awesome if not no worries
um quick back story it's a little out of
left field but I run an online community
for people that are on what's called a
low oxalate diet it's not a diet and
like the weight loss sense it's more out
of medical necessity so you would follow
it if you had certain type of kidney
stone or kidney issues some people with
Crohn's disease and some other GI issues
and a few other health conditions so in
my Facebook group I've just been like
answering questions and creating
resources for people for a couple years
I do want to start monetizing but I just
I don't want to be a dick about it I'm
trying to like put the pieces to a
revenue model together and that's okay
hey your ears
[ __ ] amazing they me I think it's
access okay what I mean by that is you
want to sell information you know that
selling information eight at a ten times
is quite douchey online if you layer
access and do what I'm doing with you
right now for two hours a week for
anybody that buys the program I think
you can amortize out the concern that
you're just selling information that
they could in theory fine but you
curated it for them add more value to it
all of a sudden goes from a seventeen
dollar book to a two hundred dollar a
month thing because we're getting eight
hours of you doing Q&A with the group I
think access is the layer that makes him
much more palpable okay
so the thing is I think that like the
basics are like there's a lot of crappy
information out there so like what I'm
doing is kind of like sorting through it
and like putting all the good stuff
together and then I feel like if people
wanted to like if they wanted access
they could get most of the information
that they need up front to you right
spending time with you right that's what
I'm saying so I think the they would
spend like an hour or two with me like
one or two sessions maybe and then that
would be like enough and then after that
what most people want is just recipes so
I think recipes are findable they can go
on Google to eventually that's the thing
they can't find anything for this diet
because there's nothing out there like
there's a little bit out there but it's
very inaccurate and it's all
disorganized listen you're more than
welcome to go content only subscription
those things tend to peter out right
layering not individual people bro two
hours a week period for all 800 people
that are in the program okay got it
I'm not talking about 54 people getting
two hours each I'm talking give me two
hours a week on top of what your plan is
well everybody comes into the room and
you bring people in like I'm doing here
and I promise you you'll build a
substantially bigger business okay cool
and I'm so I started a podcast to having
a like some scientists come on people
that do research I'm gonna try and get a
couple MDS and then I'm also thinking
about having chefs on I already did one
with one
where she's like she brought some of her
recipes and then we kind of modified him
like to this diet what do you think
about that and like having unlike other
kinds of people to have on the podcast
just doing that yes
cool name in your podcast people want to
know it's called low oxalate kitchen low
oxalate kitchen yeah so I just started
it I just recorded the first three
episodes I'm gonna upload the first one
like this week probably a that bro Lisa
yeah it's coming it's coming
all right so then one other question
completely unrelated
you remember that coin that Ryan holiday
gave you the one that's at the memento
mori so I have one of the other ones
that he made that says the obstacle is
the way so when my girlfriend saw that I
had it it was like sorta during like a
little bit of a rough that she was going
through she's had some some struggles
been through some [ __ ] so I explained to
her what it was and she was like oh she
will like I want one so but she was she
wanted one with more of like a like a
self-love mindfulness comforting kind of
vine and she's a meditation teacher so
she was like oh people could probably
meditate with it too so long story short
we ended up making some and I want to
start like reaching out to people on
Instagram or wherever really like start
sending out DMS but I'm not sure like
which people to like to target and like
what exactly they say they'd like to get
them to be into it you know target
people with something contextual to them
tell them that you admire them and you
want to send it to them and recognize
one out of every 87 people that DM you
will take it and then what if I just
send it like should I like you know ask
about it or just send it and forget it
the second you ask them to post about it
you've lost right so just send it and
then is it all right and then so one out
of 87 will reply yeah one out of every
nine will actually post it in their feed
two out of every nine will post it in
their story and that's your business
their awareness is worth way more than
your [ __ ] coin right like me posting
something in my [ __ ] main feed my dad
[ __ ] picked up twenty five thousand
followers last night yeah you know what
I mean like like you know that's worth
you don't work in ad money if you spent
it on Instagram to get the same thing to
happen is worth
hundreds of thousands of dollars I don't
weigh your [ __ ] coin yeah so you have
to be you have to be empathetic you know
like people always like oh they don't
[ __ ] post I'm like they don't want
your [ __ ] $8 T they don't want your
$9 hat you they don't want your [ __ ]
coin but but if you write something
contextual and if it hits them you've
got something a little more soulful you
might be able to convert some stuff and
that's one way to market which is an
influencer marketing for free or you can
offer to pay or you can run ads there's
a million different things you can do
but you can't be mad at the [ __ ]
influencer to not post it when their
value of it is so much greater than the
free [ __ ] thing they gave it it's
like that guy yesterday on the show I
was like hey I'm gonna give you two
things and then can you give me
something hey did you know the Roman
numeral [ __ ] five was a B yes I did
hey something horse [ __ ] then he's like
now can you record something I can put
on in front my podcast which will help
me [ __ ] build my show that was a
[ __ ] joke
I did it cuz I'm a good dude but that
wasn't like an epic [ __ ] exchange
that would be [ __ ] doing charity all
right all right
cool thank you really enjoying tea with
Gary who this morning just always
enjoying this show with everybody uh
real quick Dustin on the backend poppin
say hello they always love you yes can
you want can you get the name of our
Facebook group I think everybody on tea
with Gary Vee should join that on
Facebook like so can you talk the team I
mean is that the first in line group
like it's a closed be looking you can
see the team on the backend first time I
just closed I know that I mean here's
the Gary page and there's the Gary Vee
video experience but it's mainly just I
don't have an open group I'm not sure
I'm a little confused can heat up a team
yep Gary what's going on brother what's
up Jimmy not much man just super
grateful for everything that you do so
my question basically is that I play and
coach baseball so the the back end of
that is I played all through college my
whole life everything had a really
successful college career was
all-american all-conference the whole
nine but and then I figured I might as
well do what I should
right and I went and worked a corporate
job [ __ ] crushed it was massively
unfulfilled so said [ __ ] that sold my
car took a one-way flight to South East
Asia and just traveled for a while then
I came back and was like I missed the
game started coaching started training
and within a matter of months signed a
professional contract to go to France
and then with all that basically
coronavirus happen my flight was
supposed to be two weeks ago so now I'm
just kind of trying to figure it out but
in the meantime during Kovan I've built
a pretty decent really targeted audience
around baseball over 22 thousand
followers on tik-tok all all thanks to
you because you've been screaming out
the [ __ ] top of the mountaintops
yeah you've been yelling bro so anything
else that you say anything you're
[ __ ] yelling I'm gonna do it all in
challenge bot [ __ ] my question is is
which rabble's did you buy into I bought
into yours and I bought into Michael
Rubens I mean they're both just like
ridiculous value you kidding me bro bro
you might want to buy at least one
ticket for ten bucks on the Cuban one
you could literally be in an NBA game
gnarly
yeah my I I just got tenacious defense
though the jumpers it's not that they're
just gonna let you win at the last
minute a game and I love that but my
question is is now that I've kind of
built this targeted audience oh I'm
struggling with what do I do next is it
too late to get in the podcast game
YouTube twitch like taking off I want to
take live right now and it'll be the
show and they're like hey you need to
make twitch so I've done that in the
last week and built that over a hundred
followers got subs going and stuff on
that I just been listening to the
audience all in all in so me all of it
yes the answer is yes right the answer
is yes the answer is you're a young man
there's oh it's always the right time to
jump in you didn't miss YouTube you
didn't
miss tick-tock I've been yelling about
taken out for four years musically then
tick-tock like you didn't miss Instagram
it gets harder to get big bases tik toks
the only place you can go to 22k like
that oh yes um but but the reality is
going nice and slow on Twitch a hundred
of time we're on YouTube a hundred of
time is good too because don't forget
it's not how many subscribers you have
it's the right subscriber absolutely
like one executive at the MLB Network
sees you and the next thing you know
you're signing an 800 thousand dollar
contract to be on TV or a concert or a
high net worth father who thinks his
three boys are the next coming of the I
lose you know and yeah they're cut you
know like it's not how many subscribers
you have it's which subscribers you have
yeah true fans absolutely true fans the
one person that can change your life by
reaching out yeah
you're good we can do somebody might
just reach out to me like I want you on
TV appreciate that and if you have time
for for one more question
real fast I understand that it
definitely is the long game but how
would you recommend about going about
potentially getting brand deals on
tick-tock with baseball being being a
super turning force not yet not yet not
yet I get it
you probably have a need for money and
different things that nature but I
promise you you have you have to I'd
rather you sell that Kobe and Jordan
thing on [ __ ] eBay right now like but
listen to me sell those [ __ ] candles
like I don't give up sell your hoodie
do not go for brand deals keep building
to the audience so they have more
leverage people go in for the brand deal
too early it [ __ ] up it changes the
relationship their energy goes to brand
deals instead of making great content
and they get [ __ ] killed gotcha thank
you so much like I said super grateful
for everything that you do take care
take care yourself let's keep this going
you knew I was gonna mention that Jordan
thing Ryan I know you know Benjamin
what's good your audios not fixed
somebody just wrote tick tock is a young
audience email recipient it's young it's
gotten ridiculously older in the last
three months and it will continue to get
older just like every platform Facebook
was only college kids to remind you now
it's only grandmas talk to me Benjamin
then try reloading the page and then
coming back in first line group is
closed
[Music]
tick tock looks so much older now it is
it already is
tick tock has grown faster than insta
Krispy what's good Anthony Davis what's
good Steven Richards good orange Oh
Gabrielle Acosta let's go to next one
doesn't if we can't oh now we got
Benjamin Benjamin
hey Gary sorry about that no worries
brother hey man so um I feel really late
to the game as far as all this social
media stuff goes you know Corolla early
game Benjamin really I mean it bro hmm I
mean it I'm sorry to cut right in like
no you're just not okay like like cuz
it's not I don't know that's the [ __ ]
say you know like Charlie D'Amelio you
know you know explosion since August and
it's like one of the most famous people
in the world kind of in the u.s. right
now and she started her tick-tock
account and like [ __ ] July like
that's good to hear I mean you could
start a LinkedIn account right what do
you do I'm a trumpet player I'm
professional musician so no you have to
get on tick-tock yesterday I need you to
do me a favor
that's human use I'm telling you right
now my my daughter and her friends think
dentists are cool because they I'm being
dead serious my daughter who's 10 hit me
up six months ago she's like Gary dad
Gary dad you need to you need to be
friends with this dentist on tick tock
dentist so okay so I think have you
looked at the talk yet yeah I've like
browsed it for like 10 to 15 minutes
before hey Benjamin
we're gonna change your life right now
I'm not even kidding I'm not even
kidding I want you to spend five to ten
hours consuming tick tock I need you to
look at everything everything what that
will do is get
into the mindset of what's working on
there you'll see that you can do you see
things you can't do I can't dance I
can't do the pop in top like [ __ ]
[ __ ] so I don't dance
but I can do other things I'm telling
you right out five to ten hours start
your tick-tock make three tick tocks a
day three one quarantine the [ __ ]
like do other things jump on trends use
up the music you are going to be blown
away and watch the last person don't
baseball [ __ ] I'm telling you I'm
telling you
tick-tock I'm telling you it is it the
type of thing where I really just do
what matters to me or yes gonna follow
the trend a little bit both both yes
comma if you see something that feels
natural right so I'll show you my latest
tick tock very natural to me ready here
we go ready let me start it over cuz
everybody to see it
yeah no no booty shake and I see that no
booty shaking right and you know 600,000
views later cuz it's on trend to a Magna
stallion song that we could post that it
with what I have and I'm telling you I'm
telling you right now you will
completely come you up I think a trumpet
player is like in the perfect pocket -
and not a 15 year old trumpet player you
you I tell you I know you it will work
and how tick-tock something that
monetizes over time because I don't
really understand I see monitors
overheads
yeah but you know what else monetize
overtime when a [ __ ] dad [ __ ] dm's
you on tick tock and says I need to have
you for my bar mitzvah cuz every [ __ ]
thirteen-year-old in the world wants you
and now you're making $40,000 like a
[ __ ] rapper at a Bar Mitzvah it's
deep I like that it's smart I and I mean
for me it's really not about the money
but I need freedom and comfort I respect
the [ __ ] out of it bro I just I love I
love making music and playing so you're
gonna make $10,000 a Bar Mitzvah we're
gonna
literally clip you're gonna literally in
18 months if you listen to me and go
completely Ohio
you're gonna literally make a video
that's gonna go viral that I make
$10,000 now maritza and I'm gonna take
this video clip in 18 months on whatever
the tick-tock or Instagram is and do my
split-screen recall where I [ __ ] gave
you the blueprint and changed your
[ __ ] life I'm a hundred percent
positive man thank you you ten hours of
consumption today hang up all day I
don't want to [ __ ] hear from you
until read it all read it all watch it
all get the trends that learn it cold
learn it cold and then make the [ __ ]
trumpet tick tock tonight okay I mean I
promise you and I mean it is it
important to integrate with other
platforms I mean I I've done nothing but
to start it's the place where I think
you will explode it's also the place
where I think you'll monetize I
genuinely think you're [ __ ] playing
Bar Mitzvahs
I've played a couple bar mitzvahs but
not for ten grand how much do you get
paid I mean usually about three or four
hundred dollars for it for a good gig
that's not what hmm Wow okay get a
million followers on tick-tock and watch
that first diem come through I promise
and it's gonna open up an educational
opportunities as well cuz I'd like to
teach so I mean I want people to contact
me for the information I have yeah like
ten hours in there you're gonna personal
you're gonna enjoy cuz it's still a fun
happy silly place so just me nice
betterness [ __ ] you see you in the other
platforms and to you know make something
you're gonna [ __ ] make something it's
gonna [ __ ] suck or your natural it's
gonna rock I don't know but you gotta
[ __ ] start going but it doesn't have
to be all really geared towards my
musical pursuits or I can do eclectic
stuff as well you better know don't mix
it all but I do think you could be the
trumpet guy of tick-tock I do okay
that's do you [ __ ] play the trumpet
of the songs that are trending on
tick-tock you will win mmm-hmm you show
a little personality a little stuff like
you will win bro I appreciate this guy
thank you
good luck Ryan telling you right now if
I was born in this country I would be
running for president I would [ __ ]
win just so
yes Dustin I just wanted to say that
that was really smart the whole plate of
trending songs like I see that all the
time and work yeah and the monetization
like people can make pennies on YouTube
but if they're smart and their business
like I just told him win every 13
year-olds heart you'll be doing Bar
Mitzvahs in sweet 16s - you're [ __ ]
it'll be making a million a year it's a
trumpet guy tick tock yeah like I
remember when you sent on Joe Rogan like
how come like Joe Rogan was like saying
how I'm not I'm not making money off
Instagram but then you're saying no
you're making money off doing your
stand-up and all this it's like it's the
other things that people aren't thinking
about people want to be literal with
transact people transactional I'm Brant
yeah everyone out here thinks they're a
marketer they're a [ __ ] salesperson
I'm a marketer dadier
let's keep going hi Gary how are you my
friend how do you pronounce your name
Joey
I like the waitstaff love that how are
you doing good first of all I want to
thank you for being you and everything
you do and I wanted to tell you a little
bit of my past like I studied accounting
and finance and growing up but in have a
dream or I didn't what to do with my
struggle finding a purpose so I just I
want to become an actor after finishing
up the accounting and finance and so my
question is how do I pursue my dream to
be an actor and like without having
anyone like to back me up and also how
do I set my priorities for example like
I have debts froze up from studying
right like coming out of school I'm at a
pretty for to take courses to help me
grow keep going no I'm gonna see since I
started thinking about acting yeah it's
like
attraction it's like what you think
comes your way and it's been happening
like I've been meeting the right people
with the right connections and so on but
it's just like the reality keeps fully
through it's like I came to the
realization like I need money I knew you
know yep
what do you live so I've been up excuse
me where do you live I live in Toronto
Canada um and you're a Canadian citizen
no well yeah yeah no yeah I've been here
for Lumias um so look I think the
trickiest one is deploying the patience
and the balance of paying for your live
life and your debt off while chasing a
dream and the reality is by making the
decisions you made to collect debt for
something you didn't love that was in
essence unfortunately and is for a lot
of people and it ended up being a
quote-unquote potentially wrong decision
which is okay there's nothing wrong with
that what happens when that happens
though is it has to take longer right it
has to take longer yes so the reality is
is back to your law it's not the law of
attraction it's not like the cosmos all
of a sudden you know decided to put it
down on you it's that you're putting
yourself in a position for those things
to happen because you're thinking about
it more right and so the reality is what
happens now when you've made a decision
that is a one step backwards now every
minute has to be audited you know every
minute has to be audited meaning you
need to put yourself in a place where
you're looking at every minute you're
spending on the weekends and nights and
deploying that against behavior that
lets you get to your drink
I understand so also I want to just in
terms of recommendation like for being
out there should I get in to take
something Instagram as well what do you
think I'm gonna say well you're gonna
say yes but I mean like
I mean in terms that horse like people
get discovered someone you know some of
the like all the kids that were on vine
early and exploded are acting in movies
it already happened
Joey it already happened it was called
vine but for me but the thing is for me
like I'm more interested in like like I
think I figured out my purpose and I
know what I want to do with my life like
acting is like my dream but what I want
to do also is like I want to do it for a
purpose which is to move people move
people's hearts like change their motion
so Lake [ __ ] content I'm changing
people's emotions and hearts right now
it's free just do it stop talking about
it start doing it you got it but like
what pan is content I don't know that's
you [ __ ] if you don't know how to
[ __ ] change and move people's hearts
then you're not gonna change people's
minds and hearts like what kind of
whatever the [ __ ] you want like whatever
you want to talk about like changing
people's minds and hearts comes with
ideas and the ability to articulate that
you can do that in the written word
Hemingway [ __ ] did it in a written
word right like you can do it in a
million different ways
audio video you know written the ways to
the ways to you know communicate have
been well established this is more
getting out of doubt and getting into
clarity and [ __ ] executing I
understand you know what I mean like
like you just have to do you have to
make there is no perfect this is this is
about insecurity I understand for the so
you'd recommend someone to pay off their
best first and pursue the dream or do
both at the same time same time parallel
no it doesn't cost you don't take don't
do what you did that put you in trouble
when I heard you say acting school or
Core lessons and people want to pay to
be taught which actually means they
don't want to do you don't need acting
can lessons [ __ ] just act on
tick-tock make skits don't pay somebody
to make yourself feel like you're doing
it do it I appreciate it brother
just let me wrap this up thanks Joey
listen to everybody you know me people
[ __ ] pay for courses to make
themselves believe they're doing it when
they're not doing it just to [ __ ]
make [ __ ] great show all in challenge
please support it we're gonna end this
with my auction and then of course I
didn't put in the plug yet if you
haven't done this yeah just [ __ ] you if
you haven't signed up for [ __ ] wine
tax honestly if you buy [ __ ] wine and
you've been signed up for white X I'm
not even like I'm gonna make it less
confusing you'll [ __ ] you like what are
we doing out here like why in the world
would you buy wine from somebody besides
my dad on some real [ __ ] especially when
it's the best [ __ ] service in the
world on some real [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm just
kidding but I'm not love you guys I
don't get it you know obviously I get it
if you're an international I get if
you're in Illinois or Texas or Utah and
Michigan you can't you can't buy from
white X cos we can't shift every state
but if you're New York New Jersey
Pennsylvania you buy wine if you're
Florida and Virginia and California like
like come on like come on like why would
you buy white anywhere else Dustin but
educated you get your palate expanded
today we have a [ __ ] wine that's $22
that's 11 under 11 button $10 and change
it's the best [ __ ] white like queasy
white wine I don't get it
I'm mad a mad a mad like Donna Doherty
better sign up I'm bad like this $11 ten
dollars and seventy seven cents wine
we're gonna sell today is better than
every $20 so many along or Sancerre or
[ __ ] Riesling that people buy and
like they're gonna go to [ __ ] in Publix
or have the local liquor store deliver
like it makes no [ __ ] sense to me
Dustin your parents with wine no I
brought them empathy like they had some
of it and but like they don't drink wine
that much it's good but like Dino we
shipped Arizona please go please go to
wine Tex calm right now when we hang up
please it would mean a lot to me please
sign up look come on
all right and all in challenge please
donate to it here is what I'm offering
go buy a $10 raffle ticket and I can
spend an entire year with you doing all
of this crazy [ __ ] I am giving away the
ultimate garyvee experience how should I
go okay over the last week or so I've
been a gem with my friend Michael Rubin
and helping out on this all-in challenge
that I am accepting right now but all-in
challenge calm please go there we are
challenging some of the greatest artists
entertainers athletes in the world to
provide a ridiculous all-time experience
or one of their most iconic items in
their collection to help raise money to
help feed the hungry during this
ridiculous time and so now I have to put
up my auction so my auction the ultimate
Gary the experience here we go I'm gonna
go off the top of the head it didn't go
on all-in challenge calm to go bid on
this I am giving away okay you get to in
the course of the year you will go
garage saling with me and film trash
talk also you can get a workout with me
and Mike the Conti so I know a lot of
you pay attention to that part of my
world also we're gonna go to Wine
Library and do a $25,000 shopping spree
that's right I'm gonna pay my dad well
I'm gonna donate we're gonna pay my dad
25,000 so $25,000 shopping spree at Wine
Library I will walk through the whole
store with you tell you the war stories
and you'll buy a bunch of wine beer
liquor whatever you want food we are
going to go to a Jets game together
you're gonna tailgate with me I never do
this when I give away Jets tickets I
never let the person sit with me so you
will sit with me during the Jets game I
won't talk to you during the game I'm
completely focused but you'll get that
so the ultimate Jets experience tailgate
full game with me as well also I'm going
to give you one week play at Vayner
media so this is for you and a plus-one
by the way
two tickets the will do some plus ones
will do some just mean you depending on
with this one full week at vaynermedia
getting consulting and business advice
from team Gary B and me for the entire
week hanging out in the pit where the
shows done you're gonna be a guest of my
podcast we're gonna do a wine dinner for
you and seven of your friends at Hunt
fish club in New York City and I'm gonna
fly you all paid plus 1 2 3 of my
keynotes and we'll work on those details
the ultimate Gary the experience I hope
you bid on it I hope you get involved I
hope we raise a lot of money to help
people that need it all so what's so fun
about the o-line challenge is you get to
challenge people to be in it I am gonna
challenge all the Boehner sports
athletes I expect you in there so that
is number one number two I'm gonna go
with ooh you know what Tim Berlin the
super producer who's completely lighting
up Instagram Timbaland the super
producer I'm calling you out and finally
I got one the Undertaker
one of the great wrestlers of all time
please join the challenge everybody go
to all in challenge calm please support
this the experiences are gonna be nuts
we've been working bleeding out of the
eyeballs for the last week putting this
all together you're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media
hashtag all and challenge please check
it out and please go to your favorite
celebrities athletes and entertainers
and leave hashtag all-in challenge to
get them involved the all and challenge
please take it